افغانستان وفتى مصدر الحكوميه للجزيره
بوقوع اشتباكات بين القوات الافغانيه
والباكستانيه قرب معبر سبيل بول داك
جنوبيه افغانستان
وقعت على خلفيه اقامه القوات الافغانيه
نقطه حراسه جديده على الحدود بين البلدين
الله تفاصيل ما جرى وملابساته ولماذا يحدث
اشتباك اذا قامت الحكومه في افغانستان
معبرا على حدودها مع دوله اخرى
نعم اولا قبل ساعتين من الان وقعت
اشتباكات بين القوات الافغانيه والقوات
الباكستانيه في قرب معبر رسبين الجنوبيه
افغانستان وبضفه ولايه قندهار الناقل
الرئيسي لحركه طالبان حيث اليوم مباشره
القوات الافغانيه ببناء نقطه تفتيش قرب
الحدود وهنا عارضت القوات الباكستانيه امم
بناء القوات الافغانيه هذه النقطه ومن ادى
الامر الى اشتباكات بين الطرفين وحسب
المصادر المصيبه في الجهه الباكستانيه
والان الوضع تحت السيطره كما افاده من هذا
المصدر في ولايه انهار اصلا هذه همم من
الحدود بين افغانستان وباكستان بحدود
2600 كيلو وهناك القوات الباكستانيه حسب
المصادر الافغانيه وحسب المسؤولينغام ان
توغل داخل الاراضي الافغانيه من 10 الى 40
كيلو في بدايه قوس وفاتها كونار وتندهار
الان هناك الحكومه الباكستانيه ترى بان
هذه الحدود معترف بها دوليا واي واي واحد
يحكم هنا في افغانستان واللي مسؤولين
الافغان بغض النظر من يحكم فهم يقولون ان
هذه هي لحدود ليست معترف بها وانما هم
يسمونها يعني خط الفاصل بين افغانستان
وبين باكستان وللعلم من الوصول حركه
طالبان الى السلطه وقعت اشتباكات حدودها
بينها وبين الجيران
بعد 27 مره مع باكستان وما ايران دول في
اسلوسه طاجكستان اوزباكستان وتركمانستان
ومن بين 27
مره اشتباكات عدويه بين افغانستان
وباكستان في فترات متقاربه بحيث كان هناك
اشتباكات قبل ثلاثه اسابيع بين القوات
الاف الافغانيه والقوات الباكستانيه امن
في ولايه بكتيريكا في مديريه داندي فتان
ويدن كونان كان هناك الحكومه الافغانيه
تريد بناء الشارع قرب الحدود مما اثار
وعدد الاشتباكات بين القوات الافغانيه
وباكستانيه وكان هناك قتله من الطرفين
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا حميد الله احمد شكرا